on est débordés par des demandes du
drapeau ukraine depuis des jours on a un
afflux de commandes plusieurs centaines
par jour
[Musique]
ban
habituellement on fabrique cinq drapeaux
par an pour l'ukraine pour nos
différents clients utilisateurs
aujourd'hui on a 300 à 400 commandes
depuis une dizaine de jours et on est à
peu près 1000 drapeau fabriquer donc là
il a fallu s'organiser en enregistrant
tous les matins de commandes les
imprimés l'après-midi les met en futur
le lendemain matin et pouvoir les
expédier le lendemain après midi pour
que les gens soient livrés sous 79 72
heures quatre jours maximum
[Musique]
c'est quelque chose quand même d'assez
important leur leur montrer qu'on est là
pour eux malgré tout que même si on ne
peut pas être présent pour combattre
avec eux on est là on les soutient
[Musique]
on
bon
on est vraiment à flux tendu et du cou
du coup il répond aussi aux besoins de
nos clients habituels et historique en
parlaient d'eux
toute cette production et de cette
fabrication de l'impôt ukrainien
supplémentaires
[Musique]